so first and foremost I would like to
thank everyone and welcome everyone to
today's session the topic of today's
session is social media marketing for
SMBs and I am Kabul now I am one of the
cofounders of digital vidya welcome to
today's session you know in today's
session one of the enquiry that I want
all of you to have throughout the
session is if I ask you to formulate a
social media strategy that generates
business results with the condition that
you do not have to try selling your
services or product how will you do that
that's what I want to learn out of
today's session and to lead the today's
session we have with us Yvonne
Carmichael Yvonne at the age of 19 he
created he actually build and a sold a
company and at the age of 22 he was a
venture capitalist
he helped organization raise money with
the rain from the range of 0.5 million
to 15 million and his goal is to help 1
billion entrepreneurs and I'm just one
of them
he won really delighted to have you here
with us today and thanks for taking our
time so before I hand it over it's an
honor thank you okay great you know hey
Kapil I'm gonna be I'm gonna close the
GoToWebinar question section least for
now I was a business or anything
important comes up just let me know
sure so hey thanks everybody it's great
to be here today I'm talking about
social media strategies I know you guys
are all from different companies and
businesses I tend to focus on
entrepreneurs but all of these
strategies are applicable to the
corporate level as well so I'm excited
to start let's get into it on August
23rd 1963 Martin Luther King got 250,000
people to come to washington DC to hear
him speak he didn't have a newsletter he
didn't have Twitter Pinterest Instagram
any of that stuff and he got them to
come out to hear him speak
and you might be thinking Evan I thought
you were talking about still show media
what the heck does this have to do with
social media Tim it's important because
you guys need to stand for something the
problem with most of your social media
campaigns is that they're boring
they suck there's no feeling there's no
emotion to them you have to stand for
something important you got to think
look at the stuff that you're sharing
that your company is sharing would you
share that stuff on your own if you
weren't forced to probably not because
it's not interesting enough but doesn't
stand for anything so it's not about how
many people like your post okay it's not
about how many people follow you on
Twitter or retweet your stuff it's about
standing for something important and
when you figure that out then it's so
much easier to create a social media
campaign standing for what does your
company stand for and for most
businesses they have no idea and so if
you're not talking about your values and
what you stand for why it's important if
you're not making people feel anything
with your social media campaigns and
they're not going to share it
I stand for believe somebody wrote that
was an awesome first slide thank you I
really appreciate it but everything I do
is about believe so I believe in
entrepreneurs I believe you have to do
their do the right thing I believe that
you have to believe in yourself and and
believe that it's gonna work out even if
you don't know all the steps see if you
just see darts around is gonna work out
that's what I fundamentally believe and
that fuzes out of all the social media
stuff that I do I don't know if any of
following me you might be saying who the
heck is is Evan Carmichael guy but if
you look at my Facebook or Twitter or
YouTube or any of that stuff there's
emotion theirs feeling people engage
with it because it means something and
it means something to me and as a result
it means something other people as well
stop posting boring stuff and post
something that means something to you
this can be difficult so here's a guy
who who's tons of superheroes he's
spider-man his Ironman he's the Hulk
it can be hard to make decisions in your
business and in your life
but when you stand for something you
know what you stand for all of those
decisions become easier so for with me
and believe my social media campaigns
become easier I know what to talk about
when I'm hiring somebody in my company
they have to believe in entrepreneurs if
they don't they're not going to be a
good fit for me every decision in your
business and your life becomes way
easier when you know what you stand for
it also helps keep you motivated you
know so many people if you're an
entrepreneur or if you are working for
somebody else it's hard to be motivated
every day right you don't wake up every
single day super motivated like yeah why
not go to work this is great and the
problem is you look at you look at
motivation you look at why people get
excited to do a job it's not because of
the money you don't get all super
excited because you're making an extra
two thousand dollars this year or
whatever the conversion is in India that
that's not what motivates you who you're
rated because you're doing something
important and when you stand for
something important and you apply that
in your business and in your life you're
more motivated you're not going to be
this lazy polar bear every day you're
motivated to get to work put the hours
in because you're doing something
important you stand for something
important you're starting a movement so
what is that for your business and then
we're going to apply that to your social
media campaigns what do you stand for if
you look at some of the the biggest
names in history the people who have had
major impact the people who have changed
people's lives that people will have
stick or something you could sum them up
in one word so Martin Luther King jr. is
equality Nelson Mandela could be freed
of her Oprah Winfrey could be Hart Steve
Jobs innovation Gandhi peace everybody
has one word that you can understand who
they are and define them unbeliev what I
want you to do is find your one word and
this is really important this is one of
the most important things that
we'll ever do in your life this is that
important okay this isn't just talk on
social media right now this applies to
everything you're ever going to do in
your life you need to set your direction
and find your one word if you think
about the books you read the friends you
have the movies you like to watch the
songs you like to listen to the
companies you've started the jobs you
were or dad the folks you like the art
you like to look at all of the things in
your life that you enjoy are all tied
together by one theme there's one word
that connects everything and what I want
you to do is find out what that one word
is for you now normally I go to Twitter
and I have everybody hashtag something
that we tweeted out but I don't want to
switch platforms so what I want you to
do is put it in the questions I'm going
to load this up now what I want you to
do is write your one word in the
questions and submit it to me so I can
see what they are coming in so right now
think about what your one word is you
one word biography this is really
important you want to create a powerful
social media campaign this is where it
starts you won't want to feel like
you're living your life on her list
this is where it stops you have to
figure out this word hasn't changed for
the past ten years of your life it's
been the same word I want you to figure
out what that one word is right now and
put it to me in the questions so we've
got leadership coming in from Rob we've
got creativity coming in from red leash
keep them coming empowerment coming in
from me Shawn I hope I'm pronouncing
your name is properly entrepreneur from
fatigue solution some Ashish change from
Prashad filmmaker from joseph
meaningfulness from from Millie passion
Supriya originality I mean success value
explore positive attitude hey I mean
you're cheating there positive attitude
I want to one word this is great
okay this is great this is the most
important thing that you can do today
and if you take one thing from this
webinar I want this to be yet okay I
love these ones that are coming I look
at this one originality of my meet
Sharma it's great this is how you start
so so I look at me originality okay
every decision Jin animates like he's
doing now because he has to do something
that is original if he's working at a
foreign job doing boring things he's not
gonna be happy if he's starting his own
company he's got to be doing original
things if he's hiring people he's gonna
be bringing on people who have original
ideas that's what motivates them and
when you can define that it makes all of
your decisions easier and it also makes
it easy for people to spread your
message right we're talking about social
media here you want people to be able to
spread your message you need to make it
easy for them to do that so I love these
keep them coming in I love seeing these
come in this is really important for you
guys so let's let's bring it down to
social media how do we have success with
social media this is what most of you
guys are doing this is why most
companies are doing it's boring
you're yelling you're broadcasting
you're screaming your message nobody
cares
nobody's retweeting your stuff nobody's
sharing it like anything there's no
engagement because your stuff sucks it's
boring you're broadcasting you need to
get out of that and start talking about
important things talk about that one
word you create your campaigns around
your Wan word and if you're working at a
company then your company has to have
one word and hopefully you know your
word is not different than what your
company's word is but you need to have
the soul right you need to have
something that gets people excited that
makes them feel something so they want
to share you're getting y'all excited so
I'm gonna take baby steps here okay I
know you guys are kind of all over the
map in terms of where you are with your
social media campaign some of you are
I've been doing it for a while and a
really advanced and some of you are just
starting out so I'm gonna go from basics
all the way up to the advanced stuff as
quickly as I can because I also want to
get to your questions that's what I
really love about all of these sessions
answering your questions so this is my
five-step process okay from from basics
all the way up to the most advanced
stuff claim listen reactive proactive
movement we're going to go through each
of these and if you have questions at
the end
bring them up I'd love to help answer
them for you okay claim this is the most
basic simple stupid easiest one that you
all have to
do regardless of what your passionate
interest is in social media claim is
just go out and get your accounts okay
you need to own your name your personal
name and your company name on full than
me
it's just owned it II think you don't
know what you're gonna do it yet you may
be saying I don't get pinchers I don't
know how I'm gonna use it just go get
your name just own it so that nobody
else can take it okay that's the basics
this is a friend of mine his name is Joe
Taylor
he has a hey let's start I'm gonna stop
for one second am i speaking too quickly
Kapila am i speaking too quickly no I
think the base is perfect a flame okay
sometimes when I do webinars and
presentations where English may not be
the first language I get I get feedback
that heaven we love it but it's too fast
so I get excited but good I'm glad thank
you
he wanted me off and we'll keep going
yeah so can I call you fertilizer buddy
my name is Joe Taylor
he runs a t-shirt company here in
Toronto if you see my shirt here says
believe this is made by by Joe his cup
is called Toronto teas the problem with
Joe is he doesn't own Toronto teas the
Twitter account so he has to go with Joe
t-shirt and he's been trying to reach
out to the guy who owns Toronto teas to
buy I the Twitter account from him
because he hasn't he didn't get it fast
enough but doesn't cost anything to get
it but if you don't get it somebody else
does then you're out of luck so he's
been trying for a while to get it right
so the guy who owns his name was Mike
he's been trying to reach out to give me
a call please I want to get this Twitter
account right this is the guy who owns
Toronto teams he's not doing anything
with it he's posted eight tweets and his
life on the thing he just got there
first so he owns it and the destitute
problem from my friend Joe because this
is his Brandon he should own Toronto
teas so at least their basics go out and
get all of the accounts Joe wrote to me
and said hey even thinks you're looking
into this I've been trying for almost a
year to get in touch with this guy
different means he doesn't seem to reply
to any emails now this actually turns
out to be a good news story I reached
out to Mike who owns a
count on on LinkedIn I reached out to
him and managed to facilitate the sale
of the account so Joe now actually does
own Toronto T's but it cost him money
where you could have gotten introverted
so when all the social media networks
base six just go get your names nobody
else can take it from you hey that's
number one number two listen okay and
with each step here guys a lot of people
say social media is a waste of time
there's no ROI how do I prove this to my
boss that it works how do I prove it to
myself you know when I first started I
thought I thought it was a witch I
thought Twitter was a waste of time I
thought it was a huge waste of time and
I'm an entrepreneur okay I have I have a
busy schedule I don't have time to waste
around and futz around on on social
media if it's not getting me results so
each step along the way here guys I want
to make sure that you are getting
results that you're happy with
before you justify moving to the next
step it does make sense to dive in deep
and spend you'll hire a full-time person
to go on social media you'll have a plan
you don't know that it's working I want
you to take baby steps and true to
yourself and prove to your company if
you work at a business that this works
okay
so step two listen again I thought
Twitter was stupid what's Twitter frisky
mod I thought it was stupid a huge waste
of time people talking about their cats
people talking about their that what
they for lunch and where they're going
for dinner and I thought like this is
ridiculous I don't time for this I don't
want to be part of this conversation you
need thinking understand it is marketing
101 is you need to be where your
customers are okay you need to be where
your customers are look at this picture
you see a bunch of redheaded women if
you're a target audience for whatever
product you're selling is redheaded
women then wherever these people are
that's where you need to be whatever
conference are organized whatever event
this is picnic or whatever it is you
need to be there because you sell the
redheaded women and so the same thing
applies this is marketing 101 we're just
bringing it to social media if your
target audience is hanging out on
Twitter you need to be on Twitter right
if there's a networking event that's
happening with your audience that's
where you need to be - so just
and do a search find out if people are
talking about your industry talking
about trends that are happening because
if your customers are there then you can
justify being there if your customers
aren't there then there's no point don't
waste your time on it but each one just
go in search see if your customers are
hanging out there and starting the
conversation
yeah that's listen third is reactive
with reactive here what we're doing is
you're looking at what people are saying
about your business just by putting up
your Twitter handle your Facebook page
you know if you have a youtube channel
you just put that up on your page you're
gonna start getting some people
commenting right if I go visit a local
business I always look to see if it have
a Twitter account because I'm going to
send them a tweet so reactive is just
responding to people who are talking
about you and recognizing your champions
okay if people are talking about your
business if people are sharing your
website sharing your Twitter handle you
want to at least just say thank you give
them a who's awesome you're awesome
thank you thank you for sharing all
you're doing is recognizing your
champions recognizing the people who
love you who are sharing it because just
getting a simple thank you means that
they're gonna do it again right they
feel they feel grateful that you
recognize them and the strategy here
isn't you creating a huge network
yourself a huge following yourself but
when people who talk about you they have
their own following and they're helping
promote you so you're just saying thank
when you want them to do it more this is
got on Twitter of cats you know
ridiculous stuff I'm not gonna waste my
time what got beyond the Twitter was I
did a search for my company name and
found out that people were talking about
me talking about my website and I wasn't
a part of the conversation right if
people are talking about you you need to
be in that conversation at least to say
thank you now fortunately for me all of
the comments were good it wasn't that
Evan Carmichael's the loser and his
website socks and there were no
complaints that was good it was all good
stuff all positive comments but I wasn't
of the conversation at least to say
thank you so here are a few of them some
old ones or people wrote in and just
were we're recognizing my site in my
account and so I started just by being
your reactive and saying thank you okay
and this is how you can get started and
again prove the value because you're
having conversations on social media now
we're going to move to proactive take a
quick sip of water there this is really
important so proactive and how is you
are gonna be seen as a five-meter gonna
share on our social media channel again
that that's important right you're
taking the ideas that come from your one
word and applying it to a social media
strategy so if you're looking at Twitter
you know you don't have a certain number
of characters but if you if you have
your one word what was our one word here
originality that a meet share you want
to share tweets share Facebook posts
share YouTube videos that talk about
originality right and the people are
gonna watch it are people who value
originality and they're gonna share it
because they feel yeah that guy's got it
he understands and whatever you're
selling if you're selling shoes or
chairs or consulting services or
whatever it is when people understand
what you stand for and who you are and
they believe in you they're more likely
to talk about you to want to sign up for
your services to inquire to share
yourself with their friends when you're
blasting out coupon codes and discounts
and check out my latest blog article and
all the crap that's out there that
nobody cares about you're gonna get any
any action so with proactive start small
okay again we're starting baby steps a
lot of people they get started on this
they go crazy it's like okay I'm gonna
I'm gonna tweet three times a day and
they do that for a couple of weeks and
then this I don't know I don't know what
else to do it I'm also tweet about you
get tired you give a burnt out so start
small once a week pick your platform you
can start with wand start with Twitter
or Facebook or YouTube and do once per
week that's it make it simple make it
powerful when you read your message you
should say yeah that's right I feel that
I love that
his other people will feel the same way
so once a week but make it powerful and
then as you start to see results you can
Boop boost it up right you can go higher
you can do every day of the week you can
go higher but again we're proving value
along the way we're proving that it
works if you can't get here once a week
to work then don't go frizzy and start
doing everyday make your once a week
work and get results to have people
interact with it I love what you're
doing I can't wait for your next one to
come out okay but the quality Trump's
quality always a special in social media
where our attention span is so low we
don't have time there are Fiesta filter
so fine when someone's just trying to
sell us and we don't engage with it so
you have to have something powerful that
you put out on a regular basis keep it
consistent but start once a week and
then move up to have it being every day
of the week you can go more if you want
afterwards the last part is movement
okay and this is this is the power stop
this is the gold this is the honey this
is where nobody gets to almost because
most people are just screaming at each
other not getting any results what do
you stand for ok now we're really taking
our one word and we're trying to create
something powerful you need people to
feel something about your business
before they're gonna buy from you before
they're gonna interact with you you need
to get them to feel something through
your messaging so let me give you an
example some of the things I do ok I'm
about believe you've seen that you see
the shirt you know you've seen some of
the slides as they believe everything I
talk about is around believe and my
social media campaigns around believe
now for me I light argot entrepreneur's
most of my audience are business owners
because that's why I love helping
although it's kind of out Eva he was a
personal message so here are some of the
things that I might share ok so this is
a picture that I posted on on my Twitter
on my facebook on my Pinterest a bird
sitting on the tree is never afraid of
the branch breaking because her trust is
not on the branch but it's in her own
wings believe in yourself
I saw that message and I loved it like
yes that's an amazing message I'm making
tshirt about that so I said you know
what that makes me feel something I
would tweet this so I'm gonna put it on
my account
you have to be proud of the stuff you
create guys it doesn't have to be
something that you make yourself each
time right I didn't make this picture
but I loved it when I saw so you have to
be proud of every single piece of
content that you put out that's what's
gonna move people so that's one example
here's another one believe in your
dreams are given to four reasons the
quote but between a mayor again I didn't
make this one I'm linking to her website
at the bottom Katrina mayor calm I love
this picture again I saw it and meant
something to me it may not move you
that's okay but for people who follow me
paint likes encanta and as a book
believe or now this one doesn't say
believe in it but it still is about
belief right trusting in yourself
believing in yourself build your own
door opportunities aren't going to come
not right so not every piece of content
you put up has to have your one word in
it but it's got to encompass it so we're
building a movement for me around belief
for you around your one words that you
all shared with me that are all amazing
and hopefully guys that one word that
means something to you right you should
look at it and say you know and feel
your heart getting beating faster right
you get you get excited by you think
that this is something that that that is
your life right your whole life is
around this and so you want to share
this with other people and when you
inject your passion and your feeling and
you're sharing into your social media
campaigns
that's what's gonna ignite it that's
what's gonna get people excited I want
to share it with you here's a quick
example okay this is a difference this
is a difference on a social media
campaign when you have one powerful word
that you can rally people around and
make it easy for people to spread so
these are two videos I have on my
YouTube the first one on the right is
Chris Gardner who's a he was a homeless
guy who became a stockbroker and trusted
in himself believed in himself and
became a millionaire I put that video up
a year ago and this is still quality
content this isn't promotional junk this
is quality and I've got a hundred
thousand views in a year
okay I recently released a video called
beliefs that's it believe and I
partnered up with a with the video maker
to help create this in one month I had a
hundred and fifty two thousand views
because it was clear it was focused it
makes something a lot more powerful I
was giving people something easy to
spread now there's no advertising in
this I didn't pay for any of those views
and look at the difference it took a
year for that video my other video to
get to a hundred thousand views where
this one in a month is at one hundred
and fifty two thousand views it's been
translated into 13 languages it has
thousands of thumbs ups tons of comments
now we're at what three hundred fifty
thousand views almost on this video in
in just over two and a half months
because it's so powerful I don't have to
say anything people spread it
automatically so pick your one word and
then create all your content around that
theme because it makes it so easy to
share it's critical guys now usually I
stop when I play the video here my
presentation but I want to be able to
get to the questions I know we're sure
we only have an hour so you guys can
always go to my youtube channel or just
type in believed by my to exam and
you'll find it worth the watch
definitely if you want to see how a good
social media campaign is done
so what happens now as a result of
making it powerful injecting meaning
into all of my campaigns and giving
people a simple concept that they can
share people share it and they're out
hash tagging stuff they're out sharing
stuff with me these are a few sample
tweets I get stuff like this every day
every single day people are writing into
me their hash tagging believe they're
sharing it Twitter Facebook YouTube
everywhere the response is overwhelming
because it's easy it's coming in
multiple languages so this is in French
it says unlike all the people that are
creative it's international because
people can feel it all of the words that
you picked can strike people in any
country in the world because it touches
your soul this is who you are this is
what you want to share with the world is
the movement you're building and if you
follow that you have an ability to reach
millions of people in a meaningful way
and they'll share it for you
so again now we're applying these
concepts to all the major social media
networks Facebook Twitter Linkedin
Google+ YouTube and Pinterest is where I
would start
get those working pick the one you know
if you're just getting started click the
one where you have the most customers on
you have the most traction already start
with that and then expand the other ones
one last thing I want to talk about is I
believe you had responsibilities this is
next step up guys okay this isn't just
selling whatever product or services
you're out there trying to promote now
if you look at me I sell webinars I sell
products I sell consulting services that
the big companies are Google and dal and
American Express but you look at most of
my posts and that's not I'm not selling
them socially I stop because that's not
what it's meant for people look at my
stuff they love it the heels up and they
say I want to work with evarin how do we
work with him somehow and they reach out
to me and they buy my stuff and they get
my programs and they hire me but I
believe on top of that you have a
responsibility to once you identify what
your one word is support other people
who are going through the same problem
we're trying to conquer this same gold
or on the same mission as you are so
here's a story left at the towel I don't
know if you guys have Star Trek fans but
this is from the original Star Trek
lieutenant Uhura and she's important
because she was the first black woman on
American television who had any kind of
role of significance she was I think
third in command on the starship and at
the time black people on TV were always
they were servants they were maids they
were delivery people they never had any
kind of power and she went and did one
year with Star Trek and said you know
what I'm done I don't want to do this
anymore
I wanted to do something more with my
talent that I went on and I'm not
getting the respect I deserve I want to
go off and do something else
and she put the show and Martin Luther
King went to go see her I said you
cannot quit this show what you're doing
is important this is beyond you you're
inspiring millions of black people
across the country because now they
believe that they could do something
greater with their lives then just be a
servant or a maid or work at a
restaurant you have to keep going this
is important this is beyond you and when
she realize how important it was she
decided to keep going even though her
you know she wanted to go do Broadway
another
she decided to keep going because of
Martin Luther King's [ __ ] that's you
guys whatever your one word is to move
of your building you need to be like
Martin Luther King and shine the light
another people and help them out a quick
story about Whoopi Goldberg if you guys
know her a famous American actress she
pulled the story about when she was a
young girl she was watching TV and she
said mommy mommy mommy mommy there's a
black person on TV and she's not a maid
that's what inspired her to become an
actress an award-winning actress so
lieutenant Aurora start inspired
millions of people but it happened a
kept going because Martin Luther King
stepped in and said this is important
this is what you guys need to do with
your campaigns as well is reach out and
recognize the people who are doing great
things
who tie into your way you could have
nothing to do with your your product or
service who tie into the same one word
the same belief that you have because
when you go and help them out that's
gonna come back and help you one more
quick story when when black people in
the u.s. were trying to obtain equal
white equal right sorry there were
restaurants that wouldn't serve black
people you could go into a restaurant
and few a block they would not serve you
you would you had money doesn't matter
they wouldn't serve because you're black
a bunch of students one day decided
these are the three of them we're gonna
go and do a peaceful protest we're gonna
go sit in the restaurant and and wait
until we're surfer and we're not gonna
leave until we're we're certainly have
money we want to pick we're not gonna
cause violence we're not gonna yell at
anybody we just want to be served and
what happened they were surrounded by
everybody in the in the in the
restaurant you can see here and people
started abusing them pouring their
milkshakes on their head smearing their
faces with hamburgers you can see these
guys are covered with food that these
guys threw all over them and that would
have been an isolated incident okay
these three kids just decided to go and
do it themselves but word got out to
Martin Luther King that these guys did
it
and Martin Luther King won and told
everybody he got up on his stage and he
said way to go guys that's the right
thing to do he shone a light on them and
instead of just just being an isolated
incident around the country students now
started doing the same thing peaceful
protesting going to restaurants and
demanding that they get sir because they
have money we're not going to fight but
they started doing the exact same thing
so there are important people who on the
same mission as you who might be
thinking about giving up or who might
feel like what they're doing isn't
meaningful and it's important guys what
you're doing is important you're helping
inspired them and I think that's part of
your responsibility as a person that's
just an entrepreneur or working on a
company as a person this is something
you believe strongly in you see
something that you like you go out and
you share it and you tell them hey guys
what you're doing is important and
social media is a perfect guide we need
to do it through one quick example from
my personal experience I read this about
Martin Luther King and said hey I got to
do the same thing I gotta support people
who are taking risks in entrepreneurship
and trying to help I want to help a
billion entrepreneurs I got to help
other people trying to help
entrepreneurs too one of the things I
believe this is not enough quality
programming on television at least the
American and Canadian television I don't
know about India
that's support entrepreneurs okay we
have a couple shows but not a lot and I
discovered a show called the profit
where is an angel investor he goes in he
puts his money at the businesses that he
helps them grow and he doesn't putting
good show and it's struggling along try
and get an audience and so I reached out
to him the guy's name is Marcus lemonis
on Twitter and I said Marcus hey you
know I love the prop what you're doing
is important keep going and I don't know
if he was thinking about quitting or not
or whatever but I believe that it's part
of my responsibility to get out there
and support other people were trying to
help entrepreneurs and I try to share
his stuff and I try to promote the show
when I can and he didn't ask me to do it
he didn't pay me anything to do it I'm
not asking anything in return but I know
it's gonna come back I know it's gonna
come back either he's gonna help me
somebody else watching the show is gonna
help me it always comes back guys this
is an important part of creating your
movement around your one word so I came
back from Malaysia that's where I met
Pradeep who's losing appeals partner at
digital vidya and they invited me to
this and people were saying nice t-shirt
can I get one I'm a believer that was
inspiring I believe you know everywhere
I go I'm spreading this message if
believe hopefully you guys are feeling
something for my presentation and not
thinking hey Evan what you're saying is
all garbage hopefully you feel something
you're ready to take some action but you
want to do the same thing through your
campaigns you know you don't have to be
an eloquent outgoing professional
speaker that's cool you do it in your
own way but whenever you share something
on social media and that's the means for
you that's the test it's not how many
people are gonna like this how do people
gonna retweet this and share this it's
does this make me feel something if it
makes me feel something if I see this
picture and my heart set starts getting
excited and I get a little bit more
motivated then yeah I'm sharing that it
turned into this crazy thing everybody
wanted to take pictures in Malaysia and
hashtagging and believed and everything
was great but that's the power when you
stand for something but none of these
guys knew me coming in maybe none of you
guys know me watching this you know
webinar for the first time meeting me
but you have to have the ability to come
in and make an impact and it's so easy
when you give them something that you
feel important about and
that is easy to share so that's a quick
overview the five-step process claim
listen reactive proactive move movement
believe I was told to go to 11:30 so I'm
a little bit over my time but I want to
get to your questions again that's what
I love about all of these things is
getting to your questions so if you
you'll have a questions for me quite a
bit in there I want to answer it now is
it Q&A time I my favorite part about
these things is answering your questions
so feel free to put it in there let's go
I know there's a whole bunch of stuff
coming in Kapil is there anything that
we should hit first I haven't been
following along we've been going along
here yeah so I think guys uh since it's
a very different kind of first session
you can post your question here or if
you want to have an open conversation
just raise your hand and I'll unmute you
and we can have an open conversation as
well
by the time you do that I have one
question even from my side you know
since I'm an entrepreneur there are two
brand names have to deal with one my
name and second is digital with them so
I'm actually I want digital with their
to be promoted so but as an individual I
I really want to promote digital were
there as more than couple Nara which is
my name so what is your suggestion
whether and I'm sure a lot of
entrepreneurs would be dealing with the
similar stuff yeah and that's fine it's
okay to have it come from your company
and what I would suggest is so you're in
a partnership right so you you know you
and Freddie for together in this and
hopefully your one words are close
enough to each other but when you guys
post something I haven't checked out
your Twitter feed or your facebook feed
but when you guys post something it
should be something that again means
something to you like you have so far
everybody has a business partner you
have to sit down with your partner and
figure out what do you want this company
to stand for right we're not just
selling you know these webinars we're
not just helping people learn about
social media we're trying to do
something more important and so what is
that and then all of your posts it
doesn't have to be you sharing it on
your channel though you can - but you
can send it through did you love it yeah
and there are some brands who do a
decent job of this right if you look at
like 3m they stand for innovation and
all their stuff is innovation and the
people they hire they have to be able to
innovation
everything is innovation and it's clear
to understand what that brand is no
Springs do a terrible job
so think about Union for deep getting
together thinking about the things that
inspire you what you want your business
to stand for and start sharing content
that again you look at makes you get
excited and that's what you start with
baby
sure I'll definitely do that exercise so
now there are questions coming up so
I'll just pick them up in chronological
order I think the first one is from
Lolita she wants to know how does the S
SMB start their social media program if
you have any tips on this well I mean so
that's going through the five steps I
don't know where you are
the Leatha with your campaigns right now
but again just look at me oops I mean
then we load this back up here you look
at your five steps can't go back hold on
whatever your five steps right you're
looking at first of all you just have to
claim them right make sure you get all
your accounts right so go through those
five steps that that's how you get
started I don't know where you are at in
your path but I mean that was the whole
point of this presentation I think the
slides gonna be made available
afterwards as well we went a little fast
through everything that's right right
right even the slides yeah we'll be
emailing the slides as well as for the
present the recording of the session to
everybody right okay the next question
is from surah he wants to know how can
we choose one single word for business
any tips yeah I cannot refer to that
slide where I look at you know books
movies friends all of that it's for some
people is super easy some people like
the guys who
in here we're sharing all their words
some people find it they already know
what other people think no I didn't come
up with believe right away I didn't know
what my one word was right away I had to
think about it I had to really you know
agonize over it it took me a little bit
of time before I got to it but to find
your one word and this is a personal one
word to start with you look at
everything that you you enjoy in your
life and find the one thing that
combines all of them and then you inject
that into your business if it's your own
business it's easy because it's just you
right if it's if it's a partnership like
Apple has with Bernie then then they
have to work together and hopefully
those words are similar if you're
working at a big company then again
hopefully your one word is close enough
to the one word of the company if it's
not then you probably don't enjoy
working at your business you know if
your one word is what was that one about
being different if your one word is
different and your company does
everything the same way as everybody
else you're probably not having fun
there right that's probably not the best
job for you to be yeah but some words
could be sister words you know so you
know I work with some people who have
their own businesses and I'm thinking
about photographer friend of mine his
word is inspire and we've done a lot of
projects together you know believe and
inspire their clothes they're not
exactly the same but they're pretty
close so if you're working at a business
you're working at a company you have to
figure out what is the one word for your
business for the whole company it's
harder as you get higher up like what do
we want our company the same for this
might not be something that you can
create yourself you got to involve other
people but that's how Rick and paintings
get created your company has to stand
for something important because you're
otherwise you just broadcasting crap all
over Facebook and YouTube and Twitter
great the next question is from Rahul
he's saying that I'm a busy entrepreneur
sometime I find it hard to find times to
tweet during the day how does one work
around that
yeah and the way to do that is you start
off small right you look at my five-step
process you start with baby steps you
start once a week you start with ones to
week improve your something you're
getting results listen you're busy
entrepreneur - okay I don't I didn't
just say hey you know what I'm gonna
spend two days a week dedicated the
social media I don't have that kind of
time you only make that time when you're
singing results you have to prove
yourself and we're getting an ROI from
this but when you're tweeting a lot of
people just tweet because it feel like I
need the tweet I would put anything up
for for three weeks I got something up
well then what you're tweeting is
garbage it's it's here's a link to my
latest blog post here's here's a link
somewhere and like and nobody ends up
engaging with it so at the start it
doesn't matter so much how much you're
tweeting start with once a week but make
that tweet count man make that one tweet
that you put out mean something powerful
to you right be proud of what you
created read that can say yeah I'm
really happy with that tweet and you'll
start to see some results keep doing
that once a week until you see results
until you see people engaging with you
and then that will give you
encouragement and motivation and ROI to
keep going the the best part of my day
honestly right now is I wake up in the
morning and get my bowl of lentils for a
breakfast and I start reading through my
social media comments a YouTube Facebook
and Twitter for the most part and just
interact with people and seeing the
comments that come in and seeing
everything that you know how we impacted
people's lives that gets me excited and
gives me motivation to keep going but
when you're at that early stage again
yeah your business we're all busy that
mean entrepreneur not everybody's busy
nobody's sitting around saying hey I
have a day what do I do with my time you
got to prove it to yourself
so one tweet we make it super important
make it valuable make it mean something
to you and build up from there
great question early great Laurita has
another question she wants to know what
holds more credibility the person or his
company which is better to reach out to
reach out the person or is
I always like having a person behind the
company because people like buying from
people and not not companies right so if
you are launching a campaign it could
still be your business but it's good to
know who's behind it like don't hide
behind the logo because nobody likes
buying from a logo you want to see who's
there so if you're tweeting something if
you're at a company and maybe it's a big
company have a picture of who the person
is behind the account right even if it's
a huge company whatever the biggest
company India is that company should
have a person who manages their social
media campaigns that I can see their
face and I can react to I can ask
questions going to come back to me
because I can and we love working with
people and not companies and this is a
huge advantage that entrepreneurs have
over other people right because it's
easier for us to tell our stories than
it is for big companies there's so many
layers at a big company right if I think
about pretty think appeals business when
they're tweeting stuff out I should know
who it's coming from right like their
faces should be on their Twitter
homepage and they should have a little
sign up so I know who it's coming from
simple stuff like that you know in your
posts every now and then show a picture
of you guys
let me feel a connection to you so the
credibility it I feel always comes from
a person because this is social media
guys you gotta be social you're social
with other people that's like the basics
of being social you don't wanna be
social with a company you're social with
other people great I've been you have
raised your hand I'm unmuting you yeah
Ashwin what's your question hey one big
fan of your stuff quick if nothing has
entrepreneur and I run six different
companies myself and I'm looking to
scale up even more and further I'm
having a really hard time you know
finding good people to hit the
companies do you have any thoughts on
that yeah I'm a big believer in building
from within and and finding people who
share the same values of you who may not
have all the skills you need and
training it up to become the person that
you need this is so much easier to train
somebody who wants to learn who shares
that same one word the same values as
you but maybe a little short on the
skills then somebody who has all the
skills but as you know is lazy not
motivated looks great on paper but it's
not going to be the right fit to grow
this thing up okay so the the person
should also chill with the values of the
company and my personal values also
right absolutely number one absolutely
great thanks a lot no problem
Rahul you have raised your hem on
unmuting youth is if it's a follow up of
you know the question that's already
been asked that was about busy
entrepreneur let us know how the busy
entrepreneur yes good can you hear me
yeah I can hear you yes what I guess I
posted that question on the questions
list as well but I wanted to know I have
a company YouTube channel and I wanted
to know if it's possible to change the
YouTube channel name even though I
already registered it is there any way
around it oh I don't know I don't know I
you know I think it's possible and we
have some restrictions but it's possible
how do we go about that now what I do is
we have a new job expert in our team and
I'll ask him to mail you a blank mail
and possibly just reply to him and then
you guys can have a conversation only
thing I know is that it's a probably
will give you the further details on
that okay that would be much appreciated
welcome welcome
guys there are close to I give more with
like
big vision structure of the campaigns
not so much a technical nothing there's
that about we have digital right here so
great that's why I'm just one of the
trainers so yeah so what I was saying
was there were about 15 10 15 questions
that are still unanswered so I'm picking
them up in chronological order the next
question is from sue darshan this
question is what are some measures you
use to tie the efficacy of social media
campaign especially when it comes to
hard metrics like sales and revenue how
does that usually look for startup
businesses based on your experience yeah
this is a really hard one Michael's
based on Michael and I actually muted
you by mistake so can you please repeat
the response to this card over okay so
figuring out the ROI of social media is
complicated is not a direct line it's
not a Libra that you just pull and we're
used to you know TV spots and direct
marketing and you know Google AdWords
where you say you know this many people
want this many people convert it it's
not that kind of model it's it's like
trying to measure word-of-mouth how do
you measure that but what it does have a
major impact so first of all when I'm
creating social media campaigns
I don't do it based on quantitative data
right because I can that can send you in
the wrong direction where you're just
trying to get lots of views and lots of
lights but you're not actually put
anything out there that's super
meaningful I've gotten business in a lot
of different ways I've gotten business
from people who have bought my guides
who signed up for someone on ours
button deals not so when that Malaysia
presentation came up is where I met the
guys in digital vidya they saw my
YouTube videos they saw my YouTube
videos they said hey we need to haven't
come speak on my presentation so you
know they paid my speaking fee and they
played my my flight and my hotel over
there and that was a great opportunity
and then from there I've met I've met
lots of great people I've met you know
cut field now because of that I'm
talking you guys because of that I've
gotten brands who write to me and they
say Evan we'd love to have you crease
some content for us or help us consult
with this project you know lots of has
come from it and what I would encourage
you to do is not invest yourself crazy
heavily into social media until you're
starting to see some of those results
until you see customers writing to you
and saying thank you so much really
helped me out or until you see somebody
reaching out to you asking you about
your product or service or asking to
come to a speak speaking engagement or
consult with them on whatever project
they're having you know like get results
from like first before you go crazy
because we're all busy you you don't
have time to do the dance legit yeah and
prove it to yourself that it's worth the
time to do you're gonna get the ROI is
going to come from a lot of different
places even just having people talk
about you it's beneficial but I want you
to generate dollars right I'm like we're
in business to make money I make a lot
of money through social media but I
can't say hey you know what a hung a
tweet five more times that I'm gonna get
you know a hundred thousand more dollars
it's not that direct linear connection
but I know that when I an active on
social media I get people sharing my
stuff and then people write to me with
opportunities and so until you start
seeing it's an ROI whatever format that
means to your company don't invest
Paisley heavily into social media
so the
Scotian is from pratik kumar guys before
i actually take up this question i'm
launching us a poll in front of you you
know as part of digital vidya we provide
three months and six months training so
if any one of you is interested you know
you can just set yes yes overhead and
someone from our team will contact you
okay so the next question is from
critique Kumar this question is how much
control should have brand gave to
customers on social media so it was a
question how much control should a brand
give to customers on social media and ah
ok this is a great one now we only have
what like 6 minutes left on this so I
don't know if that's the last question
not maybe I'll just say one thing -
pranks in the question for anybody who
has and asks a question or if you still
have questions coming up leave it in the
question chat and I will make a youtube
video answer for you guys so I still
wanna be able to answer everybody's
questions I know we're kind of crunched
on time I'll leave it there and and
Camille if you could send it to me I'll
make a video response for everybody so
that they still get their questions
answered
good undo them so in terms of control
you have no control on social media this
is I mean I get into fights all the time
with brands over this and and they're
used to controlling the message you have
no control
you can't control what your customers
say about you right there is no control
and to being an active participant in it
because like it or not people are going
to be talking about your brand right if
you're doing anything important if you
have any kind of size whatever product
or services you selling people are gonna
get on and they're going to share their
experience good or bad and it's more how
you react to it that'll help shape the
public opinion around you right if
somebody's mmm
in worst comfort her and you get on
social media and you know you interact
with the person and you you're you sure
that you're a classy organization that
wins you points right if you're then
sharing stuff like most of the brands
that work with their campaigns they suck
they're sharing the worst the
worst content the content is sold boring
so bland and as a result they're getting
they get nothing no engagement happening
but just try to pump out whatever
product happens if you're sharing
meaningful information then people will
share it and they'll come to your
defense right like your your goal here
if you're trying to look at you know
customer is talking about you and how to
shape that to a positive experience with
you if you means right like say say your
Twitter feed wasn't showing up and
somebody's you know HootSuite whatever
anymore would they come back and seek
you out on Twitter because they miss
your stuff that much they would do it
for mine if if your brand means
something to you to them sorry then
people will jump to your defense
okay people love my grant and for the
most part all the comments are great but
anytime there's one comment that is not
great that says that says it's a stupid
comment or Evan you know you don't know
if you're talking about that was a
stupid video my community jumps on that
purse I have to do anything and when I
write back it's usually a funny comment
or you know thanks your feedback you
didn't they're slamming me but my whole
community jumps on them because I built
up so much equity with them that they
love everything that I create and I'm
not a special person you can do the same
thing for yourself your company if you
are providing tones of great stuff that
that touches people and is meaningful to
them then if somebody is slamming your
brand you're gonna have your customers
come to your defense but you can't you
can't control anything right like how
much control shoe the brand give to the
customers you have no control they're
gonna talk about regardless so it's your
your your action steps are one when
anybody talks about your brand good or
bad you're there you're responsive
you're fast on the trigger you're
helping to answer their questions you're
helping turn situations that as positive
they can be and a lot of times a
negative situation can be made positive
if you handle it properly and then
action step number two you again
creating meaningful content that builds
a movement that builds a community who
supports you and who love everything
you're doing and if anything negative
happens there on it help and support you
I think we're at our I think we're at
our time but um again if you guys keep
asking questions and whatever is still
outstanding I will make a video response
for you and if there is an email we have
their emails copy on yes we have the
email so we'll mail it
yeah I'll make it oh there's a lot of
questions you guys are gonna give me a
lot of work I will do it I will do it it
may not be like right now but I will do
a few guys and this is ions love
communicating with with what people and
nice too much for having me and I'm not
sure what the next step is but I've
enjoyed so much being here with you
today and answering your question great
so guys I think Robbie also asked this
question that I do not have a question
but I would like to receive the link of
the YouTube video response so definitely
what we'll do is within couple of days
you will receive the recording of this
session we'll also do a blog post on it
and we'll send a recording link to that
also in the same email and also as soon
as we are done with the the video
response of all the questions we'll send
the link to everybody okay so that's
actually that that's it from outside for
today's session there are actually a lot
of questions unanswered but I'm sure you
will receive your response very soon so
yeah that's it from my side okay
so except you party I'm sure I'm free
thanks everybody thanks Evan and looking
forward to seeing you in our other
upcoming sessions absolutely thank you